you snooze you win I am very known to
oversleep I hit snooze all the time that
extra nine minutes two minutes it's just
glorious when I wake up in the morning
and I know that I have to go to work
I just want to curl up in a ball and die
I will also set multiple alarms and just
sleepy me is not having it no matter how
determined I am when I go to bed
snooze it for life baby you tell me this
is bad for us
newsing confuses your body and mind
about whether or not it's time to get up
this may cause sleep inertia which can
leave you groggy for up to four hours
after waking that makes a lot of sense
that what coffee's for right you go
I do feel this like a lagging sense of
I'm tired I really don't feel my body
waking up until like one o'clock or two
o'clock so I guess this fact kind of
feels like it's very accurate when it
comes to my life I feel totally fine in
a nice news this morning
using throws off your internal clock
causing your body not to know when to
become sleepy pushing your bedtime later
and leading to more snoozing hmm that's
interesting because you know I actually
have trouble falling asleep my internal
clock is [ __ ] up anyway because you
know during a week we have to wake up
early to get to work and on the weekends
I'll go out late and you know be out
with friends drinking or hanging out or
doing whatever and then I think you know
yeah I'll be in bed till 11:00 or noon
which I had an earlier bedtime I have
trouble with that
so maybe the sneezing is affecting it
but I doubt it
messing up your internal clock and makes
for restless nights and sleep
deprivation can screw up hundreds of
genes that regulate your immune system
stress response and metabolism wow that
took a turn I don't know I was reading
that so joyfully that's I'm not a
scientist but no my immune system
definitely got worse over the years and
it's funny cuz as I've gotten older I've
gotten less sleep maybe that's why I'm
always stressed I've noticed nights
where I got like a shitty night's sleep
or like snooze the water or whatever I
was
more anxious and stressed out at work
did I say I think the concept of me
somehow snoozing my alarm clock changing
my jeans is scary but because it's so
scary I choose not to believe that I
don't think it's true screwing up jeans
like a sale at Macy's
scientists believe these genetic changes
can potentially increase your risk of
heart disease weight gain or diabetes
feel like I need to be in the hospital
like somebody call me an ambulance right
now
then everything cause you to die Yeah
right like all slowly dying from all
things like who care if your friends
want to hang out with you and you want
to go to sleep and they make you feel
bad about it just like you're very much
impacting my health and future so let me
sleep yeah yeah you're giving me heart
disease goodness that's what you're
doing
according to neuroscientist Matthew
Walker hitting snooze causes
cardiovascular assault on your heart
each time it goes off oh my god police
square off I get a fish I believe it's a
mini heart attack every time I hear
every time I hear my alarm go up I jump
more feet into the air I'm really scared
about hitting soon I feel like mixing on
his news I'm gonna see my life flash and
I'm gonna like be like all right it's
fine Jesus I'll get up I feel like
neuroscientists are trying to tell me
how to live my life when they don't even
know me
I wish I was more scared but I'm still
gonna continue to hit snooze like
honestly I mean I it's been a pattern
and ongoing thing for years how am I
gonna stop even with these facts in a
perfect world I wouldn't have to wake up
in the morning like I could just sleep
until my body is ready and wouldn't that
be like the healthiest thing for my body
but I have to make money I have to live
neuroscientist to live in this society
but a surprising like the severity of
stuff that can lead to but overall I
still am inclined to think it's like not
that big of a deal and I'm still gonna
face my own internal struggles waking
right into the gym anyway keep snoozing
till the day I die and then that day I
can snooze snooze till you die yeah just
do the best you can in this lifetime
what more can you do you're a snoozer
you're not a loser so I gotta say I like
that I want
[Music]